-Uh, before you go, I thought --
I thought maybe we could play a
game inspired by your new movie,
"Next Goal Wins."
What do you think of this?
-I think that's a great idea.
-Let's do it. Here we go.
-I mean...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Next Goal Wins ♪
♪ Next Goal, Next Goal Wins ♪
♪ Next Goal Wins ♪
-Now, "Next Goal Wins"
is about soccer.
In America, we don't really know
soccer that well,
but we're getting to learn.
-But here's what we do know
in America.
-Baseball.
-Yeah, we know baseball.
But here's what I have.
I have soccer balls,
I have baseball bats,
and a basketball hoop.
We're gonna bat the soccer balls
into the hoop.
Whoever gets a basket
first wins.
Get it?
Next goal --
-Next basket goal wins.
-Well, that's a sequel.
Yeah, all right, here we go.
All right.
Let's go.
-Let's do it.
-Good luck.
-Okay. You ready?
-Ready, and go, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Yes!
Ah.
♪♪
-Are you coming close?
[ Audience exclaims ]
Are you getting even close?
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
This guy can do anything.
This guy can do anything!
Taika Waititi!
His movie, "Next Goal Wins,"
is in theaters
everywhere this Friday.
Rachel Zegler joins us
after the break.
Stick around everybody.